this is the Joo underground podcast
number
81 Echo Charles sitting across from me
so about every month or so something
like that uh I get a someone at ashon
front I get a client and we'll get this
scenario that'll happen and we kind of
hinted about it on the last podcast that
we did The Last underground podcast that
we
did you know you got the the client Jim
who's the Boss
and he's in charge of you know Fred one
of the
employees and what's interesting when
you're a la front you talk to everybody
in the chain of command you know you
talk to the the SE Suite you talk to the
mid-level managers you talk to the
Frontline Troopers so you you get input
from everybody you kind of know what's
going
on and you get it from a few different
angles so anyways you have this bad
relationship here between Jim and Fred
bad communication you know things were
breaking down this is kind of Brewing
over
time and so Jim the boss you know he's
going to sort it
out and so he has you know he has a call
with Fred he tells me you know like I'm
G have a call
Fred
and he gets you know whatever next day
calls me up yeah had a I had a great
conversation with
Fred and you know I kind of I kind of
know Jim and I'm like you know been
talking to him and so I kind of know
what to expect a little bit so I asked
him a simple question I just said oh
great conversation he's like yeah and I
go how much did you talk Jim and how
much did Fred
talk and it was
silence because when I asked that
question he
knew he knew Jim knew that on that
conversation with Fred Jim had talked
90% of the time I said how much you know
he I said I said how much did you talk
how much did he talk and he was quiet
and he saids I talk too much and I said
well how much did you talk what
percentage he said I probably talk 98%
of the time which actually means he
talked 98% of the
time so I've got news for you that is
not a quote good conversation it's
definitely not a great
conversation that's barely even a
conversation that's me just downloading
that's Jim just downloading on Fred it's
a one-way conversation and that is not
communication because people forget that
the most important part of communication
is actually listening it's not talking
it's
listening you ever hear that old school
dating
advice dating advice that says oh you
know you go out with a girl ask them
about themselves and let themselves talk
you ever hear that and it kind of works
you know even if you even if you're just
meeting a someone from a business
situation you know if you just ask them
about thems eles and let them talk
that's very positive usually ends up
with a very posit gives them a positive
feeling as opposed to you go in there
and you just run your mouth for an hour
and a half during dinner yeah not
positive it's not good we're not doing
that
no
so what we want to
do is when we have problems when we have
drama when we have issues with an
employee when we have problems drama our
issues with a peer when we have problems
drama our issue with our boss and we
want to quote have a conversation about
it let me tell you what you do you
listen you listen to what they're saying
by the way this applies to children as
well this applies to your
kids when your kids are doing something
that they shouldn't be
doing or when they're behaving in a way
behaving you have to act actually listen
to why they're doing it you have to ask
them a question and listen look does
that apply to a 5-year-old sometimes
look sometimes 5-year-olds do dumb
things that you need to stop them from
doing but you get a kid that's 14 years
old you need to listen to what they're
saying you think you know everything you
think you do you think you know
everything you think you know what's
going through their mind you
don't you have to listen your wife is
mad
listen
and I'm not saying go onto the the the
warning that I gave on the last podcast
this doesn't mean like what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong no that's not
what I'm talking about we're not we're
not turning listening into
interrogation that's not what we're
doing your wife's mad listen to what's
happening listen to what she's saying
your husband's in a bad mood
[Music]
listen the more that you
listen the more you understand the more
you listen oddly enough the more you
see the more you listen the more you see
write that
down the more you listen the more you
see you cannot be detached when your
mouth is
moving you
can't think and absorb information when
you are putting out information at least
not effectively at least not efficiently
so that's what we're
doing we're
listening there you go take
it let's get into some Q&A that old
school dating advice or whatever um they
they did a I think it's like they did a
study it's funny they I always laugh
when people say they did who who did a
study they them them some someone other
than me that I read about did a study um
that so what had happened was in a
nutshell through the study that the guy
guy and guys and girls in this party
scenario right and the guy basically all
the guy did was and there's other
techniques in this study like mirroring
and you know some of that stuff but all
it was was them asking questions about
the other person and letting them talk
they didn't say the name of himself
nothing they would just ask questions
like about the other person so the other
this other person never knew the name of
the subject never knew um any anything
about the subject all they would do is
get prompted to to answer questions or
whatever about
thems and then there's you know there's
like a ranking at the end of the thing
where it's like who was the most like
who who's the most memorable likable
less like you know all this stuff or
whatever and that guy who just did the
the asking about the other person number
one likable thing and then they say okay
why' you like him whatever he goes oh he
just I just felt like he really
understood me and he was very easy to
talk to like all this stuff or whatever
and rank number one across the board
didn't even know his name big scam
right yes one big scam but damn like
that's just that's just proof you know
the that study and I actually think that
that study was conducted by the
University of Bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
Science that is a broscience university
Department uh but yeah it makes sense it
makes sense you know like you let people
talk you listen to what they're saying
they're going to be appreciative of that
yeah as opposed to you freaking barking
at them shut the hell up man you know
what's funny when you kind of detach
right I learned that when when you're
barking at someone or actually not even
barking like go back to the situation
with Fred or whatever the one you were
saying where he was like oh I had a
great conversation with them or whatever
they're literally doing the exact same
thing they're just on the other end of
it so see what I'm saying so like they
feel like it was a greaters exactly
right you know so Fred or Fred whoever
is the one who had the great
conversation is the person talking about
thems the whole time it's the same exact
thing she's they're just falling for it
on thems kind of thing you know the
thing it doesn't show is like the person
that talked about themselves is not
liked yeah so Jim like Fred thinks it's
a great conversation Jim thinks it's a
great conversation because he talked all
the time Fred's more pissed than he was
at the beginning of the convers yep ask
him why well he just wouldn't shut the
hell up wouldn't shut up doesn't listen
to me doesn't listen didn't respect me
doesn't understand so there you go man
just this such a key component big deal
it's a big deal for sure listen up
people listen up first question how do
you show empathy it's obvious what it
looks like but how do you ingrain it
into a relationship with say your wife
my wife struggles with high anxiety and
shuts down when faced with adversity I
was raised under tough love and as I've
become an adult I have three elementary
kids of my own I completely prescribe
that when needed as well as it just
being part of my character just this
morning my wife walks into our house I'm
remodeling no crew just me for the last
14 months and I can see the weight all
over her through her tone of voice her
body language her response everything so
I asked her flat out what's up why does
it seem like there's a cloud of stress
and anxiety over you she starts
explaining what's going on and I say you
got to change your thinking and pull
your mind out of this pit she shuts down
walks out saying thanks for doing
literally nothing to help me I need some
empathy with her imp potentially in
general but I don't know how to
empathize with someone so negative she
she asked me persistently what she needs
to do and it's literally doing the
opposite of the harmful negativity she's
thinking about to me it's easy to her
it's not bottom line empathy how do you
do it yeah Che much I mean first of all
like like let's make sure that
we're that is a little excerpt of what
we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Joo Underground .c And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground